[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know I'm makes me very sad because I
feel like people will never see how
effective my hips are yeah it's a good
thing these hips there's something back
you know I got a lot of great qualities
but my hips are among them I'll never be
appreciated never and then the hips are
always covered by the bottom half of the
casket him it's just wow very sad person
even see one of those display caskets
like tips up bill Richman is here hey
quarterback Garrett is here audio way
too cute Matty and overlays she's so
cute it makes me want to vomit I did
yeah that's because I'm bulimic and
Gerald a is here yes good was about to
say something about being I don't know I
just don't like myself was my wife and I
got into an argument where I found out
that she wants she wanted me to be
cremated really how do you ever say in
this another well you're not gonna be
around to have a say yeah I know but
then she got offended I said leave me on
the curb on trash day and she was a good
yeoman you want to burn me you want to
put me in a pizza oven
well it'll be other people that I don't
know you blend
I'm not a crematorium expert that's true
remember every mention analyst here
that's what happened on CNN like I wanna
i want to create create i want a
cremation analyst stat like I don't know
there's this guy it'll work with Sanjay
Gupta yes yes fire does burn showing us
back to you properly cremate someone and
then wash your hands like did you see my
scan of my lungs at yep you're yes
you're dirty so let's go see Chris Cuomo
no he's saying that he wants he's tired
of being a partisan hack yeah so he
wants to leave CNN because he thinks
that they're doing Trump's bidding whoa
whoa wait I want to be clear violence
never solves problems but there's only
one person who'd ever be willing because
he's always threatened two people
physically cuz when I train ears I do a
celeb for charity I do a celebrity fight
with Chris Cuomo of course we both have
the same combat
branch was effectively zero or the exact
same size of course you have to drug
test Chris Mayo Clinic we get it and
he'll soon be out of a job and you for
calling Fredo so it is my club
quarantine hashtag mclubbe quarantine
everything is for free of course
available in front of the paywall before
we go to an ash wednesday you enter in
the promo code quarantine and you get
$30 off because this claw this caliber
of content doesn't fund itself folk
right I don't know why I just it is
Kevin Spacey this caliber of kind of
doesn't fund itself folks stop it stop
it I didn't write it
um the way yes yes you did yeah I did
now I should have prepped more so
everyone has been asked me before we get
Wednesday though to take this political
compass yeah no apparently this is a
trend making the rounds really and so I
have to do another thing that I don't
like is it like a liberal test or what
do we know about this I don't know and I
don't care but you care so I really test
along with me I'm willing to bet that
I'll just come out as sort of basic
[ __ ] conservative with libertarian
leanings okay I'm willing to bet I don't
know but you let me know if you've taken
this test and how you turned out you
know you said yeah there were some
instruction I should yeah so there's
just a couple of there like not really
that clearly labeled it says this isn't
a survey these aren't questions they're
propositions to question the logic of an
individual one that irritates you is to
miss the point so just just to forewarn
you he's a baby
illogical proposition that's good
because the instructions irritate me
yeah exactly
this is a logic of individual ones that
irritate you yeah so I had to correct it
for them and some are extreme some are
moderate that's how we can show whether
you lean towards extremism or moderation
on the compass your responses should not
be over thought some of them are
intentionally vague so just to be clear
these are often illogical you shouldn't
think too much like what Rachel Maddow
tells us to do don't think not the time
for thinking it start um and also
they're gonna be intentionally vague
okay I already don't like it but by
popular request I am doing
I would rather be waterboarded and
people say think that I just say that
hyperbolically no I would rather be
waterboarded take this test absolutely
every test we've taken other than Jordan
Peterson's has sucked surely yeah and
that was five results right and everyone
found out all of my deepest darkest
exactly that's kind of funny I can't
suffer from an incredible guilt complex
for some reasons nothing like he's
brilliant I watched it by the way who
said that Jordan Peterson and Joe Rogan
was asserting dominance because his
palms were down mm-hmm apparently this
means I mean you no harm
except this means someplace other you
but what about the crabs are the the
animals that have read under their arms
and they show their signs of poison are
they showing you their this is back off
buddy hey back off pal you should do
that next time you're almost gonna get
into a fight someone let me know comment
yeah next time I get into a fight with a
crab walk side to side I saw those
Toyota Honda Element commercials series
of commercials for a car that was
immediately discontinued at pole
terrible its release proposition let me
read this if economic globalization is
inevitable it should primarily serve
humanity rather than the interests of
transnational corporations if economic
globalization is not what should
preserve humanity ok I already know this
how this is going to just go to a cigar
no there's a reason why we made you sign
something saying you were gonna
okay you haven't cigar to look forward
to that is defibrillator outside don't
worry no no we ran out of difficult we
asked for forty thousand they only sent
us for economic globalization apparently
serve humanity well I believe that
should I should in the world of economic
globalization a country should primarily
focus on the needs of its people so I
guess that would be disagree I would
okay disagree disagree yeah
I'd always support my country whether it
was right or wrong disagree I do feel
like if they started you know rounding
up MSNBC journalists I would make sure
that someone spoke for them so that
there would still be one to remain to
speak for me there you go so what only
one support my country weather also
where would we have rebuttals write a
very shallow pool content to rebut
weather was right or wrong so disagree
all right no one chooses his or her
country of birth so it's foolish to be
proud of it okay here's the thing I've
always you shouldn't be necessarily
proud of intrinsic characteristics just
because they're intrinsic like I'm proud
because I'm black okay I'm probably cuz
I'm white and that's why I don't really
I don't actually agree with the ideology
of sort of a white nationalist or
identitarian but there is a difference I
understand where they're coming from
here and this is why the this this poll
can't be answered poll survey can't be
answered accurately because an answer
from the United States it's very
different from any other every other
country they come from a people right a
race and ethnicity I am proud of the
United States because of the ideas that
it represents we were formed by people
who signed on and anyone who's taking
their naturalization oath knows that you
have to say all right I support these
values I want to take part and the
experiment that is basically a giant
that flag might as well waive the values
of this country so in my instance I
strongly disagree because I think you
can be proud of your country if it's a
country founded on ideals at the United
States because we ended slavery so
that's something to be proud of good
right now you and your silly little
pedestrian reductive tests and I mean
that in a way that is insulting being
reductive is nothing so bad are you
feeling on the answer soon yeah
shut up I'm doing it because the way we
set this I'm doing in my life and to
cute Maddie is doing it live so that's
why I'm saying you're
like I think I'm going to strongly
disagree with the snow and then you'll
hear alright our race has many superior
qualities compared with other races
strongly disagree again I mean if you're
gonna compare like are there are
differences like if you compare me to
probably a bill family tree height right
let's try he can crawl into smaller
spaces
yeah that's value that's a bit if he
doesn't he doesn't the Mon the coach
like airline seat because he can still
you know swing his legs like the little
Oscar market at the dock just like a
weiner dog I can't get into the fare at
home never tell you my ex-girlfriends
grandfather in Germany had a dachshund
dunks I'm not gonna I won't be reduced
to that dachshund not chasing a gopher
into a hill hmm and or a groundhog
what's the difference doesn't matter
so he's chasing a groundhog into a hill
your had a hole inside of help the
wiener dog you've gone down am i my book
so well chases the groundhog the
groundhog goes in I guess at the end
there's like a you know sorta like a
groundhog cul-de-sac and it loops around
buries the wiener dog in the whole round
Hall comes out they have to dig in from
the top of the hole took them like eight
hours oh wow dogs dog the dog was her
Wow true story brilliant gonna stay here
on augs
qualities compared with other races know
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
there's no nooch it depends on the it
depends on the context the enemy of my
enemy is my friend
i I be night either disagree or agree
dealer's choice what do you think on
this agree or disagree could agree I was
talking about like foreign policy
sometimes you have to make friends with
a lesser evil to take out the worst evil
but there's you're talking about
fortnight and based on call of duty
protocol why this test is bad yes
there's a good time having common values
and having a common enemy having common
values is more friendship and have a
common enemy it's like a co bullet
more kind of relationship so I don't
know I mean it's it's good question I
use a lot of words and said nothing so
just slowly I'm going to spite agree
[Laughter]
duly noted sir smug bastard military
that defies international law is
sometimes justified a great agree well
again this like you and is a perfect
example it's not military but I have
direct experience with this when you
talk about big tech then what we have to
please all nations then haul me out and
cuffs to Pakistan sweetheart because
they want I have actual complaints from
the government of Pakistan in other
words no the entire the United States
matters more yeah so I said okay agree
there is now a whirring fusion of
information and entertainment agree yeah
if economic globalization I'm not a
journalist I want to be very clear I am
incredibly biased wait no Rohan Singh
what is this doing oh shoot
I wasn't licking it yeah you gotta click
on come on all right so you know what
I'm not gonna actually acknowledge my
answers to cute manatee you're doing it
because I can't send my answers to the
team someone else so I'm gonna read the
next question people or ultimately
divided more by class than by
nationality for option strongly disagree
disagree agree strongly agree I mean I
guess I guess agree I guess agree but I
don't it's not in every instance it
depends it's a pain I agree as well but
if you go down to a place if you go down
to Sweden or Iceland you're gonna stick
out a little more than the United States
we're more divided by class but again
that's because we're a country of idea
is not country a country of a race of
people so I think if you if you know
personally I would say class and
nationality I would say people are more
divided by class and nationality but
there are five or six or ten other
things that are more divisive yeah types
such as morals or cultural beliefs or
good things like defined by your defined
by your beliefs to find more defined by
your family and this is really important
this this I can tell is likely written
by some collectivist if someone ever
tells you that they cared just as much
about the entire globe or even the
country
or even their town as they do their son
their daughter their wife or husband
they are lying to you and so any system
of government that is not predicated on
the idea that people will look out for
their family first is just it's a sham
okay controlling inflation is more
important than controlling unemployment
well I don't think we should be
controlling any of it but disagree I
guess I don't you can shout out so agree
because I think if you control inflation
a little bit better it'll help
unemployment hey I didn't like the I
mean maybe again the questions
themselves are so screwed up I mean the
idea that we're gonna value unemployment
is this whole idea that yeah you want to
create a lot more jobs let's go around
smash all the cars a lot more jobs we're
gonna bring those jobs back yeah I mean
you know so Moore's jobs it's not the
quality of life things all you're doing
is trying to get people to do just but
again some of these may be illogical
because corporations cannot be trusted
to voluntarily protect the environment
they require regulation I agree I don't
mean intrusive regulation agree but
there is there does need to be some
regulation a level playing field for all
of us well just there also need to be
some regulation to make sure that that
corporations aren't abusing the law
aren't breaking the law just like
individuals other words maybe some
regulations to make sure that you're not
shoplifting there also needs to be some
regulations to make sure that owners of
corporations aren't shoplifting yeah if
you're pouring something your scale
chemical and somebody else's lake that's
a problem right good like Nestle send
your letters to audio Wow from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need is a fundamentally
good idea I know from each according to
his ability to each according to his
need of the fund is this trying to say
you eat what you kill or just trying to
say that you took your exam here's
sickled go to feel their enemies this
means you make a whole bunch of money
that's fine you don't need all of it
whatever you make is going to be
distributed to people that need it okay
then disagree it's you know here's a
really interesting point or sorry
strongly disagree yeah so at a high
enough level right we all have similar
values about protecting family or love
or life it's a lot of it is the details
of how you get it done right because
even some people would be like look
might be ideally good but you can't
really achieve it like there's no real
way to do it with human beings the life
arrived and the resources that are
available so it's a pipe dream right and
then other people would go okay but if
you want to live communism just see what
Stalin did right so you're in the
communism you're in a Stalinism right oh
no no this just a different version so
it's right so in the devil is in the
details on how it gets done that this is
I think what I can already tell we're
gonna be at the end of this where the
questions are clearly gore you know kind
of getting you in a direction what
version of communism is China of the
best convinced you've swayed me my
Silhouette markets it's all yeah this
all basically depends on the but
somebody else gets to decide what your
ability is and what your need is well
that's this assumption well here's the
thing I do think that someone should eat
what they kill in other words not only
ability but work ethic right
determination I do think that people
should ultimately be in control of their
own destiny when we're talking about
physically here on earth because I
believe that God is ultimate in charge
of your destiny that's why no man has a
right to put limitations on your destiny
but if we're talking about each their
ability as determined by birth as you
see in communist countries then of
course I strongly disagree the free of
the market the free of the people
strongly agree I already said there need
to be some regulations but we should
earn the side of free markets it's a sad
reflection on our society that something
as basic as drinking water is now a
bottled branded consumer product
strongly disagree you gotta have crappy
tap water yeah
Flint it's your right you drink public
water yes it is not your right to have
Aquafina
take the water purify it reverse osmosis
it and or have it a company have it
piped to your tap by the way in every
country where they have droughts and
every country where they have a
hurricane come through and knock out all
these services they love the fact that a
company makes bottled water yeah right
could save your life
except asani that's stuff that I like to
sad stuff tastes like wet nickels I
don't like awkwafina awkwafina tastes a
little bit like the inside of a squirt
gun land shouldn't be we all know then
land shouldn't be a commodity to be
bought and sold strongly
just sit on only disagree it is
regrettable that many personal fortunes
are made by people who simply manipulate
money and contribute nothing to their
society I agree if we're talking about
like speculators and people who don't
actually run a business people who are
people here's the thing it matters if
you're talking about people who receive
bailout after bailout after bailout
that's they aren't contributing to the
economy and who are gaming the system
but I would put those people you know
corporate welfare queens in the same
camp as actual welfare queens yeah
that's not the same as a company who
employs people I think I think this
question is basically saying somebody
who has money oh the only way that they
make money is by buying and selling like
stocks and manipulating money
essentially is you this is a bad person
in society I'm like well no they're not
alright they serve a role I see even in
like a more narrow line like for example
the whole mortgage crisis provision yeah
these slits and they like go on both
sides you're not yourself you know it's
alright collateralized debt obligations
that's you know when people took
mortgages and they had they mixed the
good ones with the bad ones and we like
to a problem like that I think is the
level where you would say yeah I agree
that that it's regrettable yeah that
that's happening but the simple ability
to like lend money or you know those
types of functions we need those we have
to have those how many pages of this -
it's a 79 ya know how do we know because
we might not be doing Ash Wednesday
we're gonna have to do this this will be
the whole show might be the amazing yeah
I know
consume what is it Walter loaded hey me
had enough coffee it'll do the same in
trying to be in trying to be at this
point sir would in turn to be an
intellectual and exercise in
intellectualism it's actually simplified
stupidity it is this is in act this is
so like what are you talking about yeah
but there there are a million different
answers we could give but I know where
you're trying to go with this
protectionism is sometimes necessary in
trade agree and I'd actually become a
more Center on that since I've woken up
to you guys the only social
responsibility of a company should
B to deliver a profit to its
shareholders well hon second did you say
the fiduciary obligation or the only
social responsibility leading question
your honor by the way businesses aren't
created to have social responsibilities
they're created to deliver goods or
services which you may know as rights to
some people like bottles purified water
the people that are running the
corporations that have social
responsibility the only social
responsibility of a company should be to
deliver a profit to its shareholders I
mean I guess I guess I'll just say agree
because I think their financial
responsibility is to run the business
honestly and deliver a profit to a
challenge
the rich are too highly taxed strongly
agreed and I'm not I'm not necessarily
amongst them but when you look at we've
talked about this effect when you take
into account peak 47% of Americans don't
think they'd pay any federal income tax
then you take a huge portion of
Americans who paid very little and you
take into account the federal transfers
meaning what public schools when you
talk about public goods and services
when you talk about welfare when you
talk about ubt cars they actually pay a
net negative over 50 percent tax go back
we did a whole segment on it and I was
really upset when I dug into the
research they've done the research those
if you've done every speech Gerald
you're glib now stop taking over this
segment because you'll make me upset
[Laughter]
I miss my co-host okay those with the
ability to pay should have access to
higher standards of medical care if
we're talking about domestic borders
because guess what even the people who
are not 47% of Americans who are paying
nothing in federal income tax are able
to procure better health care than
anybody in Indonesia so what is this
international as a domestic I'll just
say it's a question-- agree there's no
strong either one of us strongly the
problems with these questions
yes numerable I mean you're essentially
going around just saying well it doesn't
matter if it's if it's a higher it's a
little bit higher can you pay a little
bit better I don't know I
the band-aid with the butterflies on it
like yeah willing to pay 7 to $50 more
for that right but what is that is it's
higher but is it below standard right
people up substandard care this next
ones are you stuck on band-aid brand
cause band-aids stick on me strongly
agree strongly agree I was convinced by
that young gentleman of color yeah I'm
stuck on band-aid brand cos germs don't
stick on me brain by the way yeah so
doesn't kill the other brand what I say
no no you have to specify forever
is this some kind is this some kind of
getting back at me for your forefathers
only a quarter of them were slaves Wow
you don't even know them seems
government should penalize business my
lawyer wants to move on penalize
businesses that mislead the public agree
strongly agree that's a perfect example
of government a business has the right
to provide a good or service even if it
offends certain people who don't like
that service especially they don't have
the ability they don't have the right to
lie to the public about it right that's
the role of the government like I've
said a hockey referee not soccer because
it's gay the reason a hockey referee
matters is because a hockey referee and
you know this being from st. Louis if it
doesn't affect the flow of the game if
it's incidental the ref keeps his
whistle in his pocket let it go
someone wants to flop go ahead and flop
over there with the other guys when man
by my sweetheart we're following the
puck a genuine free market requires
restrictions on the ability of predator
multinationals to create monopolies
agree I don't I don't anarchist over
here typically monopolies work
themselves out right how many victims in
the path of them and I don't agree
how many victims in the path of
governments that over-regulate none none
two totally fine Oh China yeah the only
the only monopolies you end up with is
the state as the monopolies and they're
all sponge of anarchy oh because it's a
it's a play on words of the the show and
he has a very nice posterior oh so high
funds is it because I wear the tighter
pants did it doesn't Gerald look like a
square-jawed version of the trivago guy
yeah I can see that life is not
threatened I was going to my mental
rolodex going Priceline that's William
Shatner yeah
trivago oh the guy who looks like the
toy soldier from that kid show who was
that guy with the plastic face in the
kid show was a bananas in pyjamas a bad
guy what abortion when the woman's life
is not threatened should always be
illegal
strongly agree yes all of three people
really but incest the question didn't
include it so don't be pedantic all
Authority should be questioned strongly
agree yeah an eye for an eye and a tooth
for a tooth there isn't even context to
that one but I'll say agree I mean you
can't have people just going around
stealing eyes and teeth or teeth yeah
you gotta be able to bury yeah when she
talked about monopoly I still saw no
competitors since ever yeah well I think
she has no concept of inflation well I
for an eye and tooth for tooth is a
quote from the Bible right that's why I
didn't want to disagree with my lord
definitely disagree down don't tell me
what to agree in if you're going
biblical okay because he brought that in
all right look thank you you've heard it
said and taxpayers should not be
expected to prop up any theaters or
museums that cannot of course strongly
to finish theaters I want that's one of
the rare incidents where I want the
government to shut them down it's local
community theater did you see our games
or the woods no I don't want to watch
cardboard cutouts and people who can't
sing a note that's why I didn't go I
like museums so I kind of was like
alright I see a public good for museums
fine we need subpar productions of
Oklahoma no one would I don't know maybe
people maybe wait wait why Bladerunner
Oklahoma I don't know what about Judge
Dredd and dies and Dolls yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I'm on Sprint should not school should
not make classroom attendance compulsory
okay this is also difficult because I
come from Canada where homeschooling was
so difficult that we only knew one kid
my entire life with homeschooled his
name was Simon and we were pretty sure
he was [ __ ] or sociopath turns out
both because he killed the guy and
didn't know why oh he just looked at him
like Michael Myers well you killed him
response school should not make
classroom attendance compulsory alright
agree we 1c beat cops running around go
swing your baton at the private schools
what is it a baton with a billy club
don't forget the way by the shopping
mall something tells me of a calculus
class to be attended what are you gonna
do that's complain yeah keep swinging
this Swedish masculine
how dare you how all people have their
rights but it's better for all of us
that different sorts of people should
keep to their own kind I don't I know
that's I know that's attempting to be
disagree good parents sometimes have to
spank their children strongly agree
absolutely agree bro
spank and not like a story that loving
was telling us before err I think there
are more effective ways a lot of times
but I am everyone else got quiet cuz you
think you can fire you know I spoke up
you just chose not to listen I made a
funny
I said I'm Pro spanking I just think
there are better ways most of the time
well that's true punishable if not
violence yeah hey do you think you would
have listened if the bamboo splinters
had come out did you get hit with bamboo
no no stab with keys once that's not
bamboo it's renewable how do you not
stab someone with keys Gerald yeah take
them off over the piano and stab you
with you talking car keys like you never
know and I'm like you know if you were
if you were a band you would be the
black hole keys I see what you think
it's natural for children to keep some
secrets from their parents strongly
agree I mean I don't really know what
some kids to keep secrets I don't know
possessing marijuana for personal you
shouldn't this be a criminal offence
is that parents secret thing a political
question trolling for underage boys how
do you feel about the nationalization of
banks also shake someone's making this
from home they're working from home and
they're like see look Johnny it's on the
test that says not keep secrets
I already selected share cookies the
prime function of schooling should be to
equip the future generation to find jobs
agree people with serious inheritable
disabilities should not be allowed to
reproduce Oh
strongly disagree you guys agree I agree
with me a few people here who wouldn't
be on the reproduction yes it was being
created by someone in Washington DC
oh I don't even want your answer because
you guys started it let's start it
you're just the only ones I still carry
the toys I'm saying it's my position but
strongly agree right I like our Lee
Army's position I'm going to cut off
your balls so that you cannot infect the
rest of the world that's disgusting
who's good who's good position was a
good person no more ball tug film Oh
save that's the only things like how
many hobos do you need to watch get beat
up we get oh yeah saw Space Odyssey
great 20-minute intro that's nonsensical
you wasted my time the most important to
learn is to accept discipline you lack
discipline I guess it I guess agree I
mean I think the most important thing
they need to know and I to interact with
the world
yeah else more doughnuts the bowl I'm
gonna tell you right now keep it in your
in diaper is rule number one okay don't
even bleep that this is going to be need
to know no I think this is going to be
the equivalent to you don't know we were
kids and we like would pop in the VHS
from I got a third birthday yeah yeah
your kid's gonna pop this yeah and sense
the underlying rage up his entire back I
have no idea how it got up there some
Mel Gibson to father's capable
Oh Jenna you are out of judges when I
peed in that's correct
wait why right when you pay before the
problem is then the Cheerios go like
they go too close to the edge I mean I'm
being for the center yeah yeah at least
I didn't you're peeing on the walls and
plus I'm not gonna let it I might have
been a spite peer - good call what is
that supposed to represent
I mean this was actually I was I was
fishing
oh yeah fishing I do it with my the
Prince Albert comes in handy
it's a Cuomo nipple ring wow that is I
don't feel good about myself I want
better from there are no savage and
civilized people there are only
different cultures strongly disagree
because cannibalism
those who are able to work and refuse
the opportunity should not expect
society support strongly agree when you
are troubled it's better not to think
about it but to keep busy with more
cheerful things I mean I think you need
to deal with it and then move on and I
think against society right now we live
in a society where people really
encourage wallowing yeah like talking
about your feelings - to be productive
to analyze them and move on but we've
forgotten about the the analysis of
moving on and now we have an entire
industry that relates to talking about
feelings yeah by the way I don't feel
good right now here's a pill yeah
that'll fix it yeah pretty much
what here's another pill for the side
take for regretting a joke that I wish
we were taping live that relates to my
being a fishing rod I believe it is
dispensed by a wall is that lexapro
Jelly Belly's
jealous Ronald Reagan knew what he was
doing when you were troubles but I think
I keep it with more cheerful things
generally agree yeah first generation
immigrants can never be fully integrated
within their new country disagree that's
not true you know why because I know
some first-generation immigrants and
this is one area where I disagree with
Indians getting mad people because a lot
of my people are [ __ ]
so it's right if you mean by my people
white but I know first-generation
immigrants who are far more American
than kids who are raised yeah my problem
is not with immigrants coming here in
taking jobs my problem is with entitled
Americans taking four-year Gender
Studies programs then demanding that
they have a job substance no problem
with the Indonesian I don't like you're
going to that no problem with the
Bangladeshi and what does Bangladeshi
she sounds like [ __ ] it does Bangladeshi
I don't wanna be racist no no this is
Pakistani and Bangladeshi okay - you
bangee
you can't call my BAE I can't call that
banky no big no-no beggars National
beggars No all right Bangladeshi
shopkeeper who pays his taxes and it's
great Philippi in America right is far
more American than migrating speakers on
campus good people are good people in
really quick point yeah
regardless of your race your background
what level of immigrant you are because
everyone immigrated here at some point I
mean it's about it's about gratefulness
and not necessarily cooperation but just
like getting along with people right and
you you could be someone who's a 10th
generation American and be not grateful
I'm not excited to be around other
people and moving forward as a country
right or is it community or as a culture
sure and you could be here five minutes
and be that person right so who's more
American Yakov Smirnoff or Alyssa Milano
I rest my case your honor done what's
good for the most successful
corporations is always ultimately good
for all of us I guess I disagree but I
don't like the questions and I don't
like created this strongly there's no
broadcasting institution however
independent its content should receive
public funding strongly agree Oscar the
Grouch should be shimmying that trash
can up to food stamps so fast
just can't spin Wow our civil liberties
master 406 god 37 minutes in I'm so
sorry fo no again it'll hit the
notification I have to do this hit the
notification Bell if you haven't yet hit
all notifications because absque rip
shins don't mean a whole lot of course
the audio podcast is available on Apple
podcasts yeah if you're 6 feet away
walking on a trail yes listen to the
buck and of course use the promo code
quarantine we have a free shows there
every day we're doing it free all this
month in all videos if you don't want to
do any of that you can't even be
bothered to it burns to it notifications
just check back every night at 8 yeah
yeah hey check that same time every day
and the live stream course on thirst and
the good morning mud club all the month
of April absolutely I knew you would
plug that because you are a part of it
[Music]
[Laughter]
no I can't we just wasted your one nice
thing I think Gerald should speak more
during Mass Monday I say you know I
literally created a show map or audio
and I said you guys are you guys are the
guys I want to hear honest so these are
the these are the points I want to
include these are the Bible verses that
I think are relevant but I want you and
go take the lead silence so it's not my
fault it's not my fault I smoke a lot no
I think you surprised Gerald is so
good-natured right but Gerald is
absolutely brilliant when it comes to
areas particularly ology just great when
we were you spend radio had a great
voice for radio and now of course you're
telling now that you know the fauxhawk
anymore in the affliction yeah that's
true
that is God laughing because it's true
there's a fleur-de-lis on his ass
employer that's somewhere in a recent
timeline there's still an imprint you
can find the young adults church group
I'm sure they'll turn up I was trying to
be callers trying our civil liberties
are being excessively curbed in the name
of counterterrorism yeah that kind of
thing a significant education of a
one-party state is that it avoids all
the are
humans at the lay progress in a
democratic completely disagree yeah
so technically it's actually true it's
just like why people say right the
problem with dictatorships isn't the
control it's the people do bad things
right but that doesn't mean that we want
a one-party state right yeah ladyboys
all the arguments like none of the
whistleblowers arena are there they
don't work right it's super easy you
don't have to like worry about counting
[Applause]
no problem not a P but that's what it
still doesn't mean it's good it's
obviously not good I mean except China
and the Mao said that it was good
although the electronic age makes
official surveillance easier only
wrongdoers need to be worried
strongly disagree strongly yes as long
as possible the death penalty should be
an option for the most serious crimes
agree I don't we have a strong opinion
on it but I agree I'm strong um
whatever's the cheapest way to dispose
of the trash kill them to us yeah just
kidding Wow Wow
I do agree though that's not an episode
of West Wing I want to see I feel like
there ought to be a death penalty
episode there was yeah and they ended up
struggling with it right well what's his
name uh Witt what's what's the guy's
name
Whitley the guy yeah yeah Bradley
Whitford
Donna it's wrong to kill people and as
for it keeps growing so they brought up
an issue and it struggled with it that
sounds like an interesting he struggled
because of his Catholic faith they're
not supposed to believe in the death
penalty apparent I didn't even remember
the I do in fact
it's so sad that he knows it's taking up
valuable space actually I love Westway I
know it was one of those things where I
started watching it late like last year
and after four episodes my wife and I
were watching blue Gerald was right
about something
it was television is television related
in a civilized society one must always
have people above to be obeyed and
people below to be commanded in a
civilized society I mean I guess I agree
in the sense that you need some central
authority and sugar doesn't me that
someone has dominion over you outside of
the legitimate purview of government but
I guess they disagree and agree on that
because there's caveat if you disagreed
at all if you disagree with that
statement the way it's framed you would
have to be an anarchist
because disagree would mean that you
don't believe anyone should have
authority over anyone that in right
right right I don't necessarily know
that keep I think there should always be
someone above you but I mean even the
president has people above them they
have international sort of
accountability let's be honest been
really care about those and they're
really doing but but always but I don't
think someone always needs someone below
them to be commanded right that's how I
read the question maybe I read it
negatively so so I don't mean I don't
know it's not a good so terrible
question wrongly disagree because I read
it in a in a different way I mean don't
change your answer keep it the way you
you you've convinced me I would say
disagree but we already entered it can I
put in disagree I'll put in disagree put
that there needs to be rule of law yes
that doesn't mean that every person
should have someone who's subservient
right the people command I read it as
though you have to like always be obeyed
someone out there you have to always
obey and then people will always have to
be commanded which I strongly disagree
with because otherwise how do you have
dissent and all that that's a very
insightful observation because I read it
as a sequel titled to as above so below
and that [ __ ] it wasn't even among the
top 5 of found VHS genres of horror
films this is written by Anton LaVey by
Joe Swanberg we watched YouTube videos
found footage questions
abstract art that doesn't represent
anything shouldn't be considered art at
all disagree I think most abstracts but
I don't agree there can be abstract art
that is a value and criminal justice
punishment should be more important than
rehabilitation agree I think II would
say I don't think I think that there
needs to be punishment punished well
that's the justice his punishment no yes
this is not rehabilitation this
questions about in criminal justice
justice is punishment fitting the crime
I think it's great if after justice we
can rehabilitate people right but when
you have places like as Ikea Sweden
right go look actually
Alexander Gustafsson who fought in the
UFC he committed like a violent crime I
think he's I don't know exactly what he
did but was violent he admitted it was
violent he were he performed to become a
better guy but he was like a hood right
he was a he was a street tough yeah I
know I know I know that's you know what
going through the rebar but you can you
can see this kind of cell he was in the
prison it was like an Ikea display why I
think there's a little bit of balance
here so I completely agree that justice
has to be served but I think we would be
better off as a society if we spend a
lot more on rehabilitation than we did
on just punishing what what should be
more important in the realm of criminal
justice punishment or rehabilitation
what is more important I'm just assuming
that you're gonna have justice in there
already maybe that's why I'm Reno but
you can't assume don't assume but said
what she's more important it doesn't say
get rid of one or the other says with
terminal justice not in what is better
for society in criminal justice I would
say what's more important is
rehabilitation that's you saying it
that's not the paper paper ask the
question I don't know it's half papers
why are we arguing
I like changes the question and then
he's like but this is my answer yeah
inside of a courtroom yeah this is going
the question really is this and let's
grab the metaphorically day one in
prison huh you wouldn't do well in
prison with those Miller deli jeans
I don't know holding and then fine
behind we said pedophiles fared poorly
in federal prison
man I can I can I cannot tolerate pet
think I wear embroidered flowers II
can't go walk right for a week it's been
like over a decade why did I do that
voice statistics doesn't mean it's right
oh no it's okay Joe homie in China so
you should feel bad for judging me I do
know it's a waste of time to try and
rehabilitate some criminals see this is
more relevant to your actually
yeah some criminals yeah the business
person and the manufacturer are more
important than the writer and the artist
hmm but a writer and an artist is a
business person in many cases right yeah
always I strongly agree I guess that I
agree in a sense but I believe it if you
this is one thing that this is the
problem with post-modernism and this is
how you know that this is created by a
post modernist because I don't
understand that art for art to have any
merit it has to provide value to some
right yeah no I agree that's what always
bothered me Oh people saying like I just
want to do this for me
really Pollock well guess what you
lucked out because for some reason
people are paying for these big exactly
but the point is if you only do art for
yourself it's of no value art is meant
to benefit the world in society and I so
I disagree I think that you can do art
for yourself you can but not not
abrogation but if someone is their
vocation that they're an artist and
they're like hey I want to do it and a
lot of folks who do the art are not you
know they're not focused on or maybe
they're you know the only time they
really focus on the money's if they're
like trying to get there you know
supplies are like to live or whatever it
may be like Green Day selling out yeah
exactly terrible right and so I in I
actually put strongly disagree because I
agree with you the first thing you said
which is the businessperson is the
artist the artist is the businessperson
well but but that's just again notice
how terribly written these questions
well but here's the thing - so you
should go with your answer they're
putting the businessperson a
manufacturer is different than the
writer an artist and so I go okay well
they're obviously saying there's a
difference between these two they don't
overlap even though sometimes they do
but the categories that don't I would
rather have more business people and
manufacturers than writers and artists
question most artists are but then you
gave that answer and you like
transformers 4 so 14 disagrees no I
agree I agree I just searched for Marin
to transpire disagree because Gerald has
horrible taste in film Hey not a word
Constantin
I appreciate that lord of war warlord
warlord no it knows Lord of war war is a
Nicholas Cage one Lord
dog what was one with a Jonah Hill war
dogs warden or dogs I haven't seen it it
turned out watch good movies we can read
the rest of it as Nicolas Cage mothers
may have careers but their first duty is
to be homemakers I was not looking at
you and you did that in it oh my god Wow
like that was encourage you if you're
watching this at home last Monday I'm a
very flawed weak person that's the
perfect person to be doing this all day
like Jesus don't compare me oh wow he's
an unfallen perfect trick question I
want to see who would correct me he's
not a guru none of you have read the
Bible he's not a guru he's not a guru
that's a Methodist don't worry the Bible
Wow okay I'm gonna get away from the
Methodists but if it takes you more than
ten minutes to find the Bible in your
house I think that's a different guy it
does that okay nary a Gideon to be found
billions mothers may have to raise but
the first duty used to be homemakers I
agree and I don't mean their mothers if
they are mothers your first now but
here's the thing mothers may have
careers homemaker can be a dedicated
career where someone can make a
wonderful home and work a job as well
yeah but it absolutely should be a
mother's priority considering that you
chose from a birth to make sure that
those children are taken care of and
that means making a house a home because
you know we got some deadbeat - just
like a man his his priority needs to be
to provide you know generally proud of
the deadbeat dads know that was actually
do not know he hasn't learned
he hasn't learned how to use sarcasm you
know what did that did I do it wrong you
gave two thumbs up by the way Siskel and
Ebert both dead I know you just figured
it out and you think it's a cool slogan
you're gonna bring up it's just a sad it
just reminds us of death still kissing
bond multinational companies are
honestly we really should have had a
beer before doing oh yeah or while we
were doing us multinational companies
are unethically exploiting the plant
genetic resources of developing
thickness I don't think this is a
exploiting the plant genetic
multinational companies are unethically
exploiting the plant genetic resources
of developing countries we gave them
GMOs and then you just rip out it what
are we talking about understand plant
genetics I love how they some like
Monsanto will go to another country
they'll take the genetics for a certain
plant to come back then they'll get a
patent on it and then they'll go back
there and they'll say hey you can't grow
this plant anymore because we have the
genome no right well Borlaug saved
billions of lives so I don't know inside
baseball of chiquita I think maybe I
don't know it's kind of a toss-up all
right you know I'm just gonna go but
agree it's an iPad it's touch sensitive
on it well you're doing it making peace
with the establishment is an important
aspect of maturity strongly disagree
because I don't disagree we shoot yeah I
said strongly disagree yeah oops strong
doesn't matter Maddie's one checking it
out for me control
astrology accurately explained if you're
an ass
Oh Steve yes you can
so this is a political compass I love it
I love it political quiz are you good
earlier are you good at keeping secrets
and twelve-year-old boy what's your sign
I'm a Libra all kids should have secret
[Laughter]
astrology I can explains many things
strongly disagree you cannot be moral
without being religious um I don't know
it's a trick question I don't agree with
that but I think for example everyone
can have a set of morals by which they
abide whether they are religious or not
but I do think that having morals that
of course are shared in a society is
necessary and that requires a religious
basis yeah I feel like the I disagree I
think that there I've known moral people
who are atheist of course unfortunately
not all atheists share the same morality
but they get not all Christians both my
question would be okay well what is
morality where does it come from what
what is the standard you're comparing to
whether if the church will still have us
charity is better than Social Security
as a means of helping the genuinely
disadvantaged okay agree yeah some
people are naturally unlucky yeah I mean
I agree this isn't a political question
yeah yes yeah I wish it was like so
you're a libertarian what does that mean
an exchange student in my high school
who quite literally slipped on a banana
peel that still happens and I watched it
go into the trash only 40 minutes
earlier only for Tom was it funny
that's fate it's hysterical that's great
slips on a banana anymore I said that it
was even funnier oh wow cuz he didn't
have a coma so she had an ID that's her
social healthcare
it is for my child's school instills
religious values disagree I agree I
disagree right because the problem is
unfortunately who do you want I don't
think that my school should be
instilling religious values because all
it takes is one bad teacher well I mean
yeah so the unstated word is public
right so if you think that you're if you
think that you want to send your kid to
a religious school or homeschool your
kids religiously that's right but again
the assumption here is that schools are
it's actually public right exactly and
to be clear with the public school I
don't want them instilling religion at
all and I don't think that the Pledge of
Allegiance is instilling religion I
don't mind I don't think one nation
under God is instilling a particular set
of religious values and I don't think
it's no I don't in Quebec we did we had
moral religious education then it was
changed to moral education you know it
still included religion in the
curriculum and I actually got kicked out
because I questioned in Islamic scholar
who came in and I said yeah what about
jihad and they kicked me out of class
yeah well but I mean instilling
religious values I don't think it means
it's just those values that are
exclusive to Christianity well here's
the problem that I also come from Quebec
where you know you basically have a
state denomination with Catholicism
right and and because I've known I know
many good Catholics here in the United
States
I hate state-enforced any kind of
religion and unfortunately between the
Catholic Church not get that right when
they've been given any sort of I think
it'd be cool to have like a comparative
religion class that'd be kind of fun
yeah but that's dealing religious values
active study of that thinks it would be
fun again I've questioned option well if
you can't make up your mind do you think
it would be nice would it be fun
would you pleasure yourself what
disgusting Jerald way to turn that
around I like that I just want to be
quiet cuz I want you to die only get
stronger
I'll fill the silence okay it'll become
worse sex outside of marriage is usually
immoral don't you know what strongly
agree there you go
strongly agree you live in hussies and
cads look at you you Queens of New
England pet [ __ ] care that was that was
the Cider House Rules filthy [ __ ] Oh
admonishing Oh addition that was wasn't
you princess of something you quit you
Queens of England yeah it's a horrible
film by the way it was nominated outside
of house rules and I saw the nominee I
was a kid and I thought well I mean I
was a candidate holiday this seems like
October sky and Jake Gyllenhaal at that
point and Tobey Maguire
seemed very similar but different
different career arcs um and I thought
like I'll goes and it looks like nice
scenery it was entirely from about
abortion The Cider House Rules
yeah it's terrible for me and Michael
Caine dies because of the chloroform
with the spoiler alert work well in case
you hadn't gotten around to it and it's
on your bucket list watching cider house
rule a same-sex couple in a stable
loving relationship should not be
excluded from the possibility of child
adoption here's the thing I agree that
they should not be excluded but I also
agree that they should be way down the
list along with single-parent households
and households that have cohabitate errs
who are not married in other words the
first people who get a kid the people
who get Amazon Prime on a child should
be married mom and dad I don't give a
rat's ass about physical attributes race
country of origin a mommy and a daddy
and land down the list we can toss and
everyone else including same-sex couples
yeah okay okay
they shouldn't be excluded from the
possibility of adoption I agree yeah
pornography depicting consenting adults
should be legal for the adult population
agree I agree don't think porno is good
for you know what I don't think that I
have the right to tell you that you
can't do what he was ashamed of making
[Applause]
here you are after hearing that story
I'm a fan of the second yes
especially if I'm looking at your sock
drawer I never used the sock we had it
out to be clear we all had to tell
embarrassing stories before the show to
warm up and bill like just overshot it
dramatically yeah I had a booger once
and a girl I had a crush on in grade
school and Bill's like okay bill wit
first telling a story the only I was
trying to make it more interesting
thanks for blowing the lid off of it
audio way I remember the next time when
you write a punchline that inevitably
includes hot hairy ass I was once was
more than one the story changes high
audio wait dad okay let me make sure it
goes okay what goes on in a private
bedroom between consenting adults is no
business of the state
strongly agree yeah that's a different
that's a different from the marriage
institution right no one can feel
naturally homosexual what that's weird a
quick a quick glance at Project Runway
makes it clear that's not true right
disagree no one hasn't feel naturally
homosexual politics yeah well this is
sex now if you would say that homophobic
I don't know these days openness about
sex has gone too far
yeah um I don't care about that in
depiction of sex in popular culture I
have no problem with people being open
about sex and talking about sex because
I think I think that's what allows me
for example to provide a retort and say
no I think that's sex within the
confines of what we believe as
Christians marriage is a beautiful thing
and a lot of wonderful Christian art of
course depicts the human form new today
no there's nothing wrong with that but
as far as a hyper sexualized culture
that's what I write yeah that's kind of
what I thought the question was asking
so that's why I said that so I guess I
agree I mean I get I don't so torn it's
the last question can you just click it
okay great now let's see where you stand
all right do we go this up what am I
nope you got a school other people there
a little I told you this is like a
number economic left-right 3.38 social
libertarian throw to zero points so like
I said I'm pretty conservative pretty
conservative with a libertarian leaning
yeah I was pretty close to you nothing
on the authoritarian side which
surprises me considering the fact that I
want to I want to round up all of
nevermind no children show I was going
to talk about a children's show but then
I realize will be a copyright
infringement not a race love you do it
unless Muppets all right now Jarrell
unless Muppets are a race yeah that's
true it wasn't Teletubbies yeah sorry
for you yet I don't want to get sued
because they're known for being with
ditches yeah but if I had my way I just
this is the problem with all of these
shows not behind the paywall is like
things that we say by the way people you
know that if it's mug Club joined mug
Club you know I use the promo code
quarantine $30 off I wouldn't stop
myself I'm not it's just that I don't
want YouTube to remove everything that's
true because of a Teletubby slash
holocaust joke in poor taste mind you
absolutely right but that hasn't stopped
me when do I get a poor taste button
right what's your result what is uh
who's taking it you were taken I took it
you got it
okay see Gerald alright I went I was
four on the right okay right and I was
actually straight just zero social
libertarian authoritarian right down the
middle
okay so you just know board the right
and then right in the middle yeah I'm
four over so you were three point three
eight so I'm just a little further right
okay yeah I don't understand how is that
because you're more socially like maybe
more eleven I conservative yeah okay
yeah what were you a half asian bill so
I was also in that bottom right quadrant
I'm a one point five on the right so
more conservative on the economic scale
and then also negative one point nine on
Liberty air yeah right about the same
level you're more Liberty
so we were both pretty similar yeah we
were very similar more the Burien than
you and he's more towards the center
than you yeah you were a little more
conservative and just slightly less
libertarian okay I will say this as much
as I hate the questions I I think I'm
probably a little further to the right
than that graph would show yeah yeah but
that does make sense to the right
libertarian that does sound about I
thought I would have seen a little
libertarian in mind but I guess not I
didn't think you're gonna see a
libertarian no you're not fun enough ah
nope not like they're telling people I
will allow it next time I give you a
pill and you don't ask questions that's
what's required by the way three
leadership at reason it's just you know
if you're one of us you'll take the pill
not just any pill anybody okay listen I
think this was a horrible waste of time
myself for having taken it but hopefully
it has served you well because you asked
for it and I gave it to you so you know
what remember that when it comes time to
renew okay if you need someone else to
tell you what you are yeah you've lived
you lived a morons life so sure that
being said I understand why people think
this is useful I don't know why hosts
out there think this is interesting but
it seemed like it was mostly accurate I
would be curious if someone knows who
created this test I'm willing to bet
that it was not a conservative America
no no because it doesn't apply all of
these rules these questions they can
apply across nearly all of Europe and
not at all in the United States just
like the First Amendment applies in the
United States and nowhere else it's not
the same question the context of the
question matters it changes based on the
country you're in and what I will say is
if they had a test to see how American
you are even though I'm a half Canadian
I would be no parts Canadian no parts no
you know be really fun just to see what
other countries ranked like Germany's
got to be like plus ten on authoritarian
so I bet you when they'd show up as
negative 10 because they try to they
always
we love the Jews now totally friends
thank you so much Wednesday we took a
split of the compass test so much we
will see you tomorrow livestream at 8:00
[Music]